- [Voiceover] Consider the
curve given by the equation
Y to the third minus XY is equal to two.
It can be shown that the derivative of Y
with respect to X is equal
to Y over three Y squared
minus X.
All right?
Write an equation for the
line tangent to the curve
at the point negative one comma one.
All right, so we can figure
out the equation for the line
if we know the slope of the line
and we know a point that it goes through
so that should be enough to figure out
the equation of the line.
So the line's going to have a form
Y is equal to MX plus B.
M is the slope and is
going to be equal to DY/DX
at that point,
and we know that that's
going to be equal to.
We'll see Y is, when X is negative one,
Y is one, that sits on this curve.
So Y is one.
So one over three Y squared.
So three times one squared which is three,
minus X, when Y is one,
X is negative one, or when
X is negative one, Y is one.
So X is negative one here.
And so this is the same thing as
three plus positive one,
and so this is equal to one fourth
and so the equation of our line
is going to be Y is equal
to one fourth X plus B.
Now we need to solve for B
and we know that point negative one
comma one is on the line,
so we can use that
information to solve for B.
This line is tangent to the curve.
So includes this point
and only that point.
That's what it has in
common with the curve
and so why is equal to one
when X is equal to negative one,
plus B and so we have one is equal to
negative one fourth plus B.
You add one fourth to both sides,
you get B is equal to,
we could either write it
as one and one fourth,
which is equal to five fourths,
which is equal to 1.25.
We could write it any of those ways,
so the equation for the
line tangent to the curve
at this point is Y is equal to
our slope is one fourth X plus
and I could write it in any of these ways.
I'll write it as plus five over four
and we're done at least with
that part of the problem.